[Music]
the house plans to vote this week on the
biden administration's
massive covet relief package faces a
really tough road in the senate where
republicans say it is just
too much money last april the treasury
department sent 1200
checks to millions of americans in
december most of those taxpayers were
sent another
six hundred dollars this latest proposal
calls for a payment of fourteen hundred
dollars more
along with other benefits cbs news
business analyst that's jill slesson
joins us to sort it all out for us jill
good to see you let's start with the
1400
who gets it in this new plan if you have
income up to 75 000 as an individual
or a 150 000 as a married couple
you're going to probably get this 1400
check
a couple of differences from the past
two checks that 1200 and the 600
this 1400 will also be eligible for
older dependents you got a smaller
amount for kids in the first couple of
rounds
and this is for older kids those college
kids and they're probably going to get
that full 1400
the phase out means that you're going to
get less money if you make above those
thresholds
and you're completely phased out if you
make more than a hundred thousand as an
individual
and that would be more than a hundred
fifty thousand i'm sorry uh
two uh two hundred thousand as a couple
so these are numbers that are really
good for families
and i'm very excited about that
dependent number because it really helps
many more families
i'll say older dependents you mean over
the age of 18. is that what you mean or
over the age yeah they want exactly 18.
all dependents so even if they're in
their 20s and they're your dependents so
if you're in college you're still going
to get that 1400 check that's big
let's talk about unemployment numbers 10
million americans still out of work are
there any plans laid out in this plan
for
unemployment benefits here absolutely
remember the plan that was passed in
december gave uh people who were out of
work an extra 300
of federal benefits that number is set
to go up to 400
per week on top of your state
unemployment
and remember by the way gang don't
forget this is taxable income to you
stimulus checks or not these are taxable
dollars
but what's really interesting is that
other stimulus is running out in march
march 11th this would take us through
probably the end of
august for that extra unemployment that
would be great news because a lot of
these jobs are not coming back it's
going to take people
a longer period of time to find new work
and you know this jill it sort of picks
up what you just said a lot of families
are still struggling financially
is there anything else in the bill that
would help them
there is a big push to help the people
most impacted negatively by covet and
that is
the people who make less than 50 000
there are some really important aspects
of this an expansion
of sick and paid medical leave for
families that will be
very important for those people who
don't have insurance right now
we also are likely to see an expansion
of the child
tax credit up to three thousand dollars
for child thirty six hundred if your
kids under the age of
six and then a big piece for this tax
season
the earned income tax credit this is
usually for
lower wage americans they're going to
expand
the level at which you can receive it so
you put these three things together
that's a lot of help for american
families
it's also why the price tag at 1.9
trillion is starting to balloon
because of all these extras that weren't
in previous plans yeah joe one more
point of help potentially right now
there's a 15 minimum
federal wage in the bill if that
survives will it survive how hopeful
should people feel right now
uh i don't think it's likely to survive
there's a technicality about whether
this can actually get in through budget
reconciliation which is how the
democrats are likely to pass this but
just to remember 15 minimum wage exists
in many places many states are moving
that way
i think we are on the path to getting to
a 15 minimum wage and by the way
you think it sounds like a lot of money
it's about 31 000 bucks a year so
we're not talking about paying people a
hundred thousand dollars a year
i don't think it gets into this bill but
the democrats led by bernie sanders are
really pushing hard on this one all
right we shall see jill schlesinger
thank you very much
uh i want to talk in a mention here
about the stock trading platform robin
hood which
is increasing customer support after
being accused
of not giving clients enough help and in
one case that alleged lack of help
causing a young man's death now robin
hood says
it is adding hundreds of full-time
registered financial reps
it did it last year it's gonna double
that number this year
in a statement robin hood said quote we
want to make sure we're
there for customers especially in time
sensitive situations
specifically mentioning live phone
support for customers
with options issues now that is exactly
the issue that alex kearns faced we
may recall we told you about currencies
a 20-year-old who mistakenly believed he
had lost nearly three-quarters of a
million dollars in failed options trades
he took his life last year after robin
hood did not respond to several emails
for help
we spoke to his parents about it do you
think if robin hood had somebody
manning an email account or picking up a
phone
that alex would be here absolutely yeah
i have no doubt
he just wanted an answer he just needed
a little help
he could have gotten answers to those
questions and there was nobody there to
to do that for him the currents family
has filed a wrongful death lawsuit
against robin hood the trading app
said at the time it was devastated by
the current's death
uh this could help other families for
their family of course though
yeah you hope life goes on because it's
not going to help the current family but
it does sound like robin hood is
listening yeah yeah they're definitely
taking action
when one would hope what were you going
to say no just you know i hope they're
listening
i mean there was a demonstration at a
congressional hearing where they got a
recorded message again yeah it's like